foreign
fundamental about human nature that that
causes us to focus more on crisis and on
the dark side but Meg why didn't you
start I mean I I would say that there is
something in human nature that causes us
to focus inordinately on a kind of
pornography of dark and light and I was
I was trying to find someone who spoke
Latin earlier so I could really get to
the basis of the word pornography
because all the definitions
just say it's all about naked ladies
um but but I would I would Define
pornography as sensation without content
and
I think it's no coincidence that the
internet you know the biggest searches
on the internet are pornography of which
88 apparently has an element of violence
um and cute kittens and they're both so
they're both exactly part of the same
um sensation without content
and I think
um
that there is a there is a tendency
there is a real attraction in human
nature to sensation without content
because it's
um
it's it's back to
um what we were saying before about
children eating too much sugar it's
um
sedative
it it doesn't cause you to think too
hard you don't have to think too hard
about human nature uh it's just more and
more and more sensation and it comes
down
probably to the question that we all
asked if we ever did a philosophy class
in sort of sixth grade where they said
you know if you could hook you and and
it's what what you were saying as well
if you could hook your brain up to have
nothing but happy Sensations for the
rest of your life would you do it
um I have to say I kind of go for it but
I know not everybody would answer that
way but it's interesting that you say
it's a sedative because I would have
thought it might be a stimulation it's
the opposite of a sedative it excites
people to see violence and Gore and
planes crashing into skyscrapers and
that sort of thing yes but it's sedative
in terms of
sedating the the uh the human
requirement for stimulation
it's uncomplicated stimulation it's it
satisfies it it fills those receptors
so Romeo and Juliet uncomplicated yes
indeed I'm thinking I'm interested in
this word sedative as well because I
think um the studies tell us that people
have to increase their level of
extremity when they consume porn and
consume they do once it's consumed it's
gone they need to do the next level up
it's a bit like gamifying and perhaps
there is an element of sedation going on
there because people become renewed and
and oblivious to to what was level one
and before you know they're at level two
level three level four and it becomes
more and more extreme and it's well
known that that pornography
um ruins people for actual sense8
um consensual sex
it no longer does what it's supposed to
do because the sensation levels have
become so high that they can't be
matched by real life
but but I wonder whether
um just moving away from porn for the
moment
um when when we get excited by watching
violent films or uh in deep planes
flying skyscrapers or rubber necking
what we're actually doing is trying to
learn from the experience so we're
trying to think you know if I read this
book about
um I don't know a woman who's been
horribly abused maybe if it happens to
me I'll be able to deal with it better
because I've because I've sort of lived
through it vicariously do you think
there's some sense of okay that's a kind
of learning but there's another kind of
learning which is to learn to explore
those very difficult feelings in oneself
you know people for a while wondered and
got worried why it is that when we read
folk tales and fairy tales to children
they're so full of you know death and
murder and hunger and you know people
you know trying to eat you for breakfast
uh but children actually are not
terrified by those experiences because
they're experiencing those stories and
the comfort and safety of their bed with
mum or dad or their carer reading those
stories to them so that they know
themselves that they're not about to be
eaten by a big bad scary wolf or you
know hit hunted down by the Axeman so
it's about appreciating those darker
shades of human experience in a kind of
safe environment and I think that's what
stories do for us all the time and we
still do that as adults when we go to
the theater when we I remember studying
Revenge tragedies you know that kind of
Jacobian phase just after Shakespearean
and and I remember quite a few of us
were questioning why on Earth is this
entertainment these are full of death
destruction rape violence the most
appalling uh crimes but it was it was
like this cathartic experience but also
this ability to make sense of the
difficulty and the challenge of
experience
and I wonder whether as our lives on
average actually get less violent uh I
mean we do of course have a rather
violent um virus trying to attack us but
but generally less violent maybe we
maybe we seek out fictional violence
more what do you think Nick
um well I think there's the there's the
recognition uh of the nature of life
that we there is there's Love and Death
there's there's creators existence and
there's destruction and then there's the
question of the representation of that
um and um it's no bad thing that we want
to represent the things that are
important to us and of course children
you can't fool children uh and uh so you
know so they want their Tales are going
to also represent the the things that
are important
um which they know are important the
question is then is sort of what we do
with that and then how you whether
whether you could whether the the
representation in fiction or films or
whatever of the negative side of things
can be used in a positive way and that's
that's the challenge in many ways um so
a philosopher Nietzsche for example was
um predated Freud but he very much was
aware of these negative sides to human
nature but he saw the task as as using
them in a positive way so we you know
we're aware of death and we have this
destructive urge but maybe if you can
turn that around and channel it in a in
a way uh which is creative absolutely in
some ways that's that's the sort of
challenge that many if you can do that
but that's not easy when on the other
hand we're being sucked into the sort of
more sentimental
representations which really are a
denial of that reality and I and I
actually have a problem and back to this
idea of you know pornography in The
Wider sense I mean I'm not talking about
sex pornography necessarily but
um a huge amount of of well I mean I I
know for certain that the sale of
um detective novels murder mysteries
um
uh violent films goes up when the
economy is doing well
so when everybody's feeling safe and
happy we need more kind of sentimental
violent stimulation without very much
content
literature
you know it's what I do for a living I I
believe in it more than anything as as
a forum to be able to allow people to
experience things that they're never
going to be able to experience in their
own lives or they won't be able to
experience maybe for a number of years
however the vast majority of of
writing of books of stuff that sells of
movies
doesn't actually grapple with those
subjects it presents it as a kind of
sentimentalized version you know the um
about 15 years ago there was a big
series called
um a boy called it does anybody remember
that was that about a boy who'd been
horribly brutalized by his mother and
forced to eat [ __ ] and lived in a box
and then both of his siblings I think
sued
the brother because they said no that
never happened in our family for me the
interesting take out of that is of
course that every family is like
rashaman you know you're looking at it
from different versions of a prism and
what one child's hideous upbringing was
another child's perfectly happy
upbringing
um but what I remember about that was my
child was in uh primary school and there
was a little girl who was in her class
who uh had a terrible terrible family
situation in fact I'm not even sure she
had a family I think she was fostered
and
um your mother was drug addict and she'd
uh I really had an incredibly horrible
time and her favorite books in the world
were these books A Boy Called It Now was
she trying to make sense of her
own personal situation
possibly was it encouraging to her to
think that somebody had a worse life
than than she had or was there just a
kind of sedation in this
um this voyeurism
um sort of and and actually I think it
goes all the way up to the book of prize
I mean I won't I won't mention
particular titles but you can ask me
after but you know there are awful lot
of books that have won the book of prize
recently which I I read as a kind of
voyeuristic porn which give you really
creepy horrible vile experiences but
don't actually give you the kind of the
the the content the literary the
literary substance that makes that kind
of stuff meaningful
yeah um I was supposed to be a bit
controversial aren't we oh yes please
I hope you won't be offended but I mean
I mean there's something going around
here which is the sort of there's the
bad literature the sort of pornographic
literature and then there's the good
sort now Plato I know that I'm a big fan
of Plato he had the view that all
literature
um was very impressive and very
seductive and we should treat novelists
both of you with the greatest of respect
as we escort you to the city walls
yeah
um because it's too dangerous well no he
thought there was another there was it
wasn't just the sort of the Badlands
show it was that it was an inevitability
of failing to grasp
um the truth about reality which is that
uh it's part of the business of of
literature to distort
um and it's always uh in like it's all
it's always a distortion and it's not
just the sort of the bad kind which I'm
I'm sitting here sort of saying oh well
is this bad stuff and what I do is much
better that all literature has that
function of well and not just literature
music I mean indeed indeed so you gotta
but if you want to grasp the horrible
reality you've got to grasp it as it
were nakedly without representation of
any kind which is inevitably going to be
distorting I think I think Plato's
trouble was that he had this notion of
this Perfection this impossible
Perfection and that anything we could
try to do to in inverted commas
represent that Perfection would be
necessarily imperfect therefore all art
is imperfect all art is incomplete all
art is lesser than this notion of the
sublime so I think he tripped himself up
on that Old Chestnut and shouldn't that
be putting us out into the into the
extreme ends of the Empire that's very
good reply I have to say but but
actually moving on from that even
non-fiction you could say is distorting
I mean I spent most of my life as a
journalist and we're much more likely to
report bad news the good news but and I
remember writing columns about this
saying this is the first year since
anyone can remember in which we haven't
had a winter crisis in the NHS yep and
as a result probably thousands of lives
have been saved and this is a fantastic
news story but it's not reported on
because it's never actually it's not an
event it's a process but that's because
journalism is like
pornographic literature in a way
journalism is offering uh sensation
without
content to some extent there's a lot of
content there too no there is content
there and I'm a good you know I
I
I'm all for a journalists I'm always
very shocked when they come down below
kind of just a great suppose you know
I'm politicians yeah I think that's a
really good strong movement now though
which is constructive journalism and
it's it's rigorous it's relevant it's
not just like happy clappy you know the
world's a great place but it's actually
a movement and it's it's to combat this
exact Trend and there's um I don't know
if anyone's seen a website magazine
called positive.news for example it
seems to be a fairly good benign example
of this and just this week they reported
that four endangered species of tuna has
been you know shown to be saved they
also reported on the Global Peace Index
which actually confirmed study by study
by study that more countries were more
peaceful last year than there were
countries that were not peaceful and
this minor small gradual Improvement is
actually incredibly good news because of
course we have this impression from the
news that everything's getting worse and
people are more violent and people are
living in less peace so in a site or a
magazine like that you have reporting
that covers that sort of story and it is
a story just like your story about the
NHS you know a winter a crisis being
avoided this year it's how it's reported
it's where it's reported another another
really specific way in which this
constructive journalism operates is that
it offers
um ways of con you know concrete ways of
actually making the world a better place
so five realistic concrete ways that you
can help an Afghan Refugee you right now
in Britain so rather than listening to
the news and feeling helpless and inured
because you feel helpless it actually
opens up a little opportunity for you to
be constructive and actually do
something about an issue that matters to
you or something that affects you but I
mean I think that's great though on the
whole people don't buy that sort of
media coverage
to continue watching this video click
the link in the top left or in the
description below or visit iai.tv for
more debates and talks from the world's
leading thinkers on today's biggest
ideas